let's go to the next story you want to
do megan fox you want to do bill burr
what story do you want you tell me what
story you want
the olympics we teased that one you want
to do the sex one okay let's do anti-sex
bets in the olympic village a social
media theory
is soon debunked okay page five if you
want to go to this
so kai you want to pull up that video
where the kid jumps on the bed
so anti-sex beds in the olympic village
social media theory is soon debunked the
new york times competitors arriving at
the tokyo olympics have discovered
something unusual about the beds and the
athletes village they're made out of
cardboard organizers say it's the first
time that the beds at the games
will be made almost entirely out of
renewable materials but in the time
of the coronavirus when olympic
organizers worried about transmissions
or trying to discourage close contact as
much as possible the unusual bed frames
have led
some to suggest there is another motive
behind them paul chelymo kalimo an
american distance runner speculated on
twitter that the beds were
unable to support more than one person
and were aimed to at avoiding intimacy
amongst athletes soon the beds were
being labeled on social media as
anti-sex ryan
mcclengan a gymnast from ireland called
the claim fake news a video he posted on
twitter showed him jumping on top of his
bed demonstrated that it could only
withstand it could withstand
vigorous activity the official olympics
twitter account reposted his video
adding thanks for de-punking the
debunking the myth here's the video
in today's episode of fake news at the
olympic games
the bats are meant to be anti-sex
they're made out of cardboard yes
but apparently they're meant to break at
any sudden movements
it's fake fake news news
he's a gymnast he only weighs 15 pounds
i mean come on
by the way is brandy love an alternate
on any of the olympic teams she might
just show up out there
you know like these guys wouldn't be
able to figure out to throw that
mattress on the ground right
but you know sex is such a big deal at
the olympics they hand out condoms right
you know that's always a big story 160
000 they've handed out in japan and the
record is what 450
000 that they did in rio it would be
interesting to find out what really does
go on in those olympic villages
i mean that's a lot of condoms what are
you saying i'm saying
like there's a lot of sex that goes on
you know are you saying like if somebody
if an olympic athlete had an only fence
chat and showing in their bedroom like
they would get millions of people that
would buy is that kind of
are you saying a business model i'm
saying it would be fascinating to learn
i mean they got a lot of downtime
they're all athletic a lot of hormones
they're all a lot of them are very very
attractive i mean you can see it makes
sense but you just
you don't associate that with the
olympics but it's clearly going on
in a very very big way it's a lot of
condoms
i i'd look at that and i would say
challenge accepted boy
let's let's let's bust some boxes baby
you know imagine the sumo wrestlers they
got to sleep on some cardboard out there
bro
i look at that and i'm like man forget
sex that doesn't have the structural
integrity for my lumbar man like
first of all who's still having sex on
beds this is 20 20 grow up people
like you know you got to find some some
exciting things to do here so you're
saying it's fake news
you're going to find them on the counter
it wasn't me he even saw me on the sofa
i think it totally makes sense there
would be a way for them to try to take
any sort of fun and enjoyment out of
life and
i can see the initial reaction is that's
what they were doing but but it's it
there's gravity they'll be all right and
they'll be fine yeah you're going to
stop yeah so you're not buying it you're
going to stop no i don't think it's an
answer
athletic 25 years it certainly wouldn't
stop anybody because you just take it
right off the bed you throw the mattress
on the ground uh-huh
is that what you would do yes i'm an
olympic i have a
trained you know look i mean
where there's a will there's a way right
i mean you know we could we could
problem solve this thing together
this is uh i i got to tell you man
the the dumb stuff that comes out of the
olympics every like there's just
do you figure they do this like every
two years right there's a winter
olympics there's a summer olympics and
they just can't figure it out
like everywhere they go they they leave
a wake of destruction in all of these
cities
like they basically destroyed brazil
right like they just destroyed the place
well and even beijing they build all
these
you know venues and then they're never
used again like how many times do you
need a velodrome
right hey by the way what's your level
of interest in watching the olympics
they start this week
the opening ceremonies are friday listen
the other day i showed the
gymnastics to dylan and dylan didn't let
me change the channel huh hey
and it was women's gymnastics i was so
impressed by my son it was one of those
moments where i'm like i'm proud of
everybody well
they kept saying leave it that leave it
that i want to see it
so that's good news for nbc has 7 000
hours of programming oh boy it's a lot
man
seven thousand seven thousand what do
you pay for something like that um
what's the number you know
their profit in the last picks was 250
million i thought the profit would be a
little bit higher
the the rights fees are probably about 3
billion per olympics i would imagine do
the athletes get paid it's amateur isn't
it
no no no they're paid now for sure no
they could be professionals not a big
number though yeah it's not a big number
is it sponsors how do what what makes it
worth four years of training
to swim 50 meters the elite or the gold
medal
i mean yeah the way gerard said what is
it worth me
training four years to swim 50 meters
you know that's a good point
you know what is it worth are you
kidding me yeah it's cardboard beds
are you serious for the rest of your
life
lifetime supply a cardboard bag and i'll
be able to tell the story there'll be no
money
and this year and this year they get all
consciousness and this year they get to
put on their own medals as well
oh nice so they're not waiting for
anyone to look is that right
you know i'm not a look i feel you know
then this kind of goes against my my
entirety of uh
personal choice and freedom on this here
we go
i got to tell you the people that don't
want to stand for the anthem like why
are you representing your country i
don't get that man i that that
like to me that's the easiest opt out in
the world yeah the ioc said they're
going to punish them
if they do it we'll see because you know
what's going to happen i mean these
protests are already being
formulated in the minds of some of these
athletes whatever yeah
i look forward to watching the world cup
olympics i there's a few events i
actually like so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you're not subscribed to the
channel
please do so take care everybody